what's going on there my hat is
backwards it's backwards today just like
the world and the oscars mom it's
symbolic
what's going on reject nation greg join
with john today we are going to talk a
little bit more about this whole will
smith slapping chris rocket the oscars
situation has been the talk of the town
we've been following it quite a bit and
we weren't planning on really doing a
follow-up but will smith issued an
apology that we haven't read yet but i'm
like well we gotta check this out that
happen last night so he got this
what's he gonna say today we all wanna
know what he has to say because so much
has been coming out that i've been
getting non-stop messages about chris
rock apparently refusing to proceed with
an investigation with the lapd into this
suppressing charges there was a lot of
talk about maybe will smith potentially
having to give back his oscar variety
did an article today talking about how
the oscars have launched a formal review
into the whole situation they have of
course done their mandatory pr situation
of we we condemn violence on all
accounts we condemn it we'll still give
him the oscars
during the show when it's actually
happening because we can't afford to
lose any more time than we're already
these are good ratings too yeah good
ratings more people tuning in than ever
as variety wasn't covering any no they
were speaking about how there's going to
be some types of disciplinary action or
sanction perhaps but it's unlikely that
he would have to give back his oscar
there's a lot of people who they've said
and might have to get back their oscar
and they just haven't of a few names
come to mind right away apparently will
smith did actually issue an apology and
so we wanted to kind of react to it in
real time and discuss it let's face it
if you go online there are so many
different camps here a lot who want to
explore the gray area of the situation
and there's a lot who are just flat out
team chris rock or team will smith on
the situation you get both sides of the
argument this is stirred quite the
debate so you check out my video that i
did yesterday but let's go through this
together man so will smith says
big willy stun
okay let's get though we'll get serious
here he says violence in all of its form
is poisonous and destructive my behavior
at last night's academy awards was
unacceptable and inexcusable jokes at my
expense are part of the job but a joke
about jada's medical condition was too
much for me to bear and i reacted
emotionally
yeah i mean i'll go into i was talking
with some other youtubers about it today
in this little group chat and i'm gonna
share some of that with you guys but he
goes on to say i would like to publicly
apologize to you
chris
i would do it again no i would
apologize to you chris i was out of line
and i was wrong i am embarrassed and my
actions were not indicative of the man i
want to be there is no place for
violence in a world of love and kindness
and there's a second page here john you
want to read it absolutely i would like
to i would also like to apologize to the
academy the producers of the show all
the attendees and everyone watching
around the world i would like to
apologize to the williams family and my
king richard family i deeply regret that
my behavior has stained what has been an
otherwise gorgeous journey for all of us
i am a work in progress sincerely
will
all right he issued an apology to chris
rock directly yeah because he did issue
an apology during his speech to the
academy to his nominees you know pretty
much to everyone there except for chris
rogers
one glaring omission and i'm sure with
the oscar oscars officially launching a
review he has to say something he just
got to the point where he has to say
something i was talking with some
friends earlier today and i was like if
you boil it down to the most basic thing
that i think happened the guy is always
under a lot of pressure he just reached
boiling point he reached tipping point
sure when he like saw i talked a lot
about it in the video but the most basic
version is that they laugh at the jokes
and like it was a polite laugh like it's
not a funny joke i don't even mean like
it's not funny because it's offensive
i'm like it's it's just not it was it
wasn't just a funny joke the joke's
outdated it's so low-hanging
stupid joke all right and then it's
offensive in the fact of how you know
it's it's making fun of her medical
condition if that is indeed what chris
rock was actually doing you know when he
saw jada's reaction how hurt and
bothered she was by it feeling the need
to publicly defend her i think he just
reached a tipping point and lost
perspective on the whole situation and
just reacted with going up there and
hitting the guy do i believe that he
could have still expressed his anger
sure do i believe that he could have
just not reacted with a smile and all
that yeah do i think he should have gone
up there and hit him a lot are saying
you did the right thing will he should
have done you stood up for your woman
sure if you feel that i'm not gonna
fight with you on it i don't think he
should have done that and clearly he's
apologetic about it for a reason i don't
consider it a thing of him backing down
necessarily i think that he knows that
that wasn't the smart wisest
professional thing for him to have done
although the action of standing up for
your woman is a pretty hot thing to do i
can't deny that it's a pretty sexy thing
to
with a good amount of people from just
yeah being willing to do that on a
national stage i mean you know part of
it is i wonder too he's right in front
with all the cameras and he's got to
know oh dang they they probably caught
every moment of this i got to fix this
now but yeah i mean you know for some
people that is what should happen more
often the thing too that i was thinking
about from his perspective you know when
you're sitting there he's at the front
row the only thing separating to him and
the presenter is a small flight of
stairs as opposed to like having people
in front of you he looks over his wife
gets a joke made at her
he hears a whole auditorium of people
laughing
pretty much you can interpret that as
they're laughing at her i need to defend
her so he reacted emotionally as he
admits here what i'm saying is i'm not
out of the realm here of like oh i can't
believe he did it like i just don't see
where it comes i really think he reached
tipping point especially after the
amount of public defending and spotlight
and scrutiny the will smith and jada
pinkett smith relationship has just
consistently had and just seems to get
bigger and bigger all the time in my
mind i'm thinking you should just wait
some of the after party to hit him if
you really want to i mean that's what
people forget like people happens all
the time
some shitty cell phone footage yeah you
know if you've got a beef with it with a
guy you must know pretty well then yeah
save it for a place where you know
rowdiness might be a little bit more
it's not it's never in the decorum to
just walk up and slap somebody i guess
but it's a lot more understandable at a
party environment than live on stage
while you're both at work and at a
mutual celebration party of sorts yeah
like there's way more to it than just
the two of you at an event like that and
it seems like this is the kind of thing
that could negatively affect way more
people than just will smith chris rock
and jay to pink it you know in an
environment like that on a national
stage you know it can very much embolden
the wrong people the event's not just
about them you know and it became all
about this when there's a lot who really
wanted to be celebrated and deserve to
be celebrated as well i feel like the
apology is needed to be issued to me i'm
like there's there's a lot of like gray
area i'm in that camp i'm in the gray
area camp on a lot of this if you watch
the other video i really dive into it
one thing i forgot to mention i thought
it was pretty baller how chris rock
managed to handle that situation i
thought the way he handled it oh getting
hit did a good job on just standing
there and he knew how to transition
away train rolling and didn't didn't
really even bat an eye i mean that's the
thing you got to credit chris rock with
is that sort of unflappable like hey the
most unexpected thing just happened and
i'm just going to keep grinning about it
and keep the show rolling one thing too
is that will smith and chris rock they
have history they've been at least
photographed publicly together it's
seeming like they're friends and if you
pay attention to their lives of what
they've expressed about their
upbringings and their backgrounds both
of these dudes are two tough ass mofos
they're both tough
as much as chris rock is like mr funny
guy and often can be self-deprecating
and stuff he's a tough dude as well you
know it is just an interesting conflict
that occurred and i think this apology
is something that is very much necessary
and at the end of the day there are some
people who are definitely going to be
out there saying oh well why'd you back
down i don't think that's the case i
don't i feel like he absolutely had
every right to defend his wife's
integrity and he had every right he had
every right to defend her maybe he
shouldn't have gone up on stage and hit
chris rock but he's owning up upon his
own reflection too at least with his
words that was not the right thing for
him to have done and he apologizes to
chris rock directly about it so we have
to just move forward with that and then
we form our own opinions if you had an
issue with will smith doing that if you
can accept his apology or not that's up
to you
i say do it
say force your emotions give them a pass
come on who cares who cares it was
entertaining let it happen again next
year we'll get everyone to slap chris
ryan
it'll be like that airplane [ __ ] yeah
that's perfect it'll be another awkward
routine but anyway guys what do you
think about will smith's apology i would
have liked to have have it been a video
instead of just a one of these like text
forms because i think a lot of
communication comes down to body
language and tone to you know register
sincerity as much as possible however
the most we can do is just take it as
sincere since he's issuing it
on his own personal social media
accounts
all right well we'll talk to you guys
soon
[Music]